it also became clear that there was one
other way to increase the capacity of a
communication system we can increase the
number of different signaling events for
example with Alice and Bob's string
communication system they soon found
that varying the type of plucks allowed
them to send their messages faster for
example hard medium versus soft plucks
or high pitch versus low pitch plucks by
tightening the cable different amounts
and this was an idea implemented by
Thomas Edison which he applied to the
Morse code system and it was based on
the idea that you could use weak and
strong batteries to produce signals of
different strengths he also used two
directions as Gauss and Weber did
forward versus reverse current and two
intensities so he had plus three volts
plus one volt minus 1 volt and minus 3
volt for different current values which
could be exchanged it enabled Western
Union to save money by greatly
increasing the number of messages the
company could send without building new
lines and this is known as the
quadruplex Telegraph and it continued to
be used into the 20th century but again
as we expanded the number of different
signaling events we ran into another
problem for example why not send a
thousand or a million different voltage
levels per pulse well as you may expect
fine-grain differences lead to
difficulties on the receiving end and
with electrical systems the resolution
of these differences is always limited
by electrical noise if we attach a probe
to any electrical line
and zoom in closely enough we will
always find minut undesired currents and
this is an unavoidable result of natural
processes such as heat or geomagnetic
storms and even layton effects of the
Big Bang so the differences between
signaling events must be great enough
that noise cannot randomly bump a
signaling event from one type to another
clearly now we can step back and begin
to define the capacity of a
communication system using these two
very simple ideas first how many symbol
transfers per second which we called
symbol rate and today it's known simply
as bod for a meal bod oh and we can
define this as n where it's n symbol
transfers per second and number two how
many differences per symbol which we can
think of as the symbol space how many
symbols can we select from at each point
and we can call this s and as we've seen
before these parameters can be thought
of as a decision tree of possibilities
because each symbol can be thought of as
a decision where the number of branches
depend on the number of differences and
after n symbols we have a tree with s to
the power of n leaves and since each
path through this tree can represent a
message we can think of the number of
leaves as the size of the message space
and this is easy to visualize the
message space is simply the width of the
base of one of these trees and it
defines the total number of possible
messages one could send given a sequence
of n symbols
for example let's say Alice sends Bob a
message which consists of two plucks and
they are using a hard versus soft pluck
as their communication system this means
she has the ability to define one of
four possible messages to Bob and if
instead they were using a system of hard
versus medium versus soft plucks then
with - plucks she has the ability to
define one of three to the power of two
equals nine messages and with three
plucks this jumps to one of twenty seven
messages now if instead Alice and Bob
were exchanging written notes in class
which contain only two letters on a
piece of paper then a single note would
contain one of 26 to the power of two or
676 possible messages it's important to
realize now that we no longer care about
the meaning applied to these chains of
differences merely how many different
messages are possible the resulting
sequences could represent numbers names
feelings music or perhaps even some
alien alphabet we could never understand
when we look at a communication system
now we can begin to think about its
capacity as how many different things
you could say and we can then use the
message space to define exactly how many
differences are possible in any
situation and this simple yet elegant
idea forms the basis for how information
will be later defined and this is the
final step that brings us to modern
information theory and it emerges in the
early 20th century